in today's video we're going to cover
the top 10 magical creatures you want in
hogwarts legacy
people of the internet's retro records
who are here if we're meeting for the
first time i'm just a dad who loves
games and the stories they tell we post
videos every week here on youtube and
also stream
over on twitch i promise the twitch
streams they're coming back guys i
promise
for all the latest hogwarts legacy news
be sure you subscribe to the channel so
you don't miss any of the new updates
rumors or
theories about the game here we've
already talked about the confirmed
magical creatures using
information from the trailer official
wallpaper and a playstation blog post
but what about creatures we haven't seen
just yet look magical creatures are
going to play a huge role in hogwarts
legacy i even think they're going to be
an incredibly crucial aspect of the
game's main story lines
so even though we know about quite a few
already i think we're going to see
plenty more
in the final game but which creatures do
you guys
want the most well i asked you on a
previous video i've been checking the
reddit and here we
go let's get into the list and then i'll
tell you which ones i think have the
best shot to make it into the game
and once you've heard my take be sure
and leave me a comment down below
letting me know which creatures from
this list you think
will or won't make it into the game
we'll start with
the creature that i would say is
probably the most requested i've seen
and that
is the phoenix this is no surprise
considering how
powerful this creature is in the
wizarding world harry potter fans got to
know the phoenix quite well in the main
series through fox who was albus
dumbledore's personal phoenix
fox of course played a prominent role in
book two of the series harry potter and
the chamber of secrets
helping harry to defeat the basilisk and
eventually healing his wounds with
phoenix tears
fox also helped dumbledore make his
escape in harry potter and the order of
the phoenix
he even took a killing curse from
voldemort head on in the battle at the
department of mysteries
avada kadavra did indeed destroy the
phoenix then and there but
can you ever really kill one of these
creatures of course we know fox would
later be
reborn from the ashes which is by far
the phoenix's most
incredible ability they're insanely
powerful beings which is why they're one
of the few creatures in the wizarding
world whose feathers can be used in
wand making up next we have nifflers we
were first introduced to these little
guys in harry potter and the goblet of
fire
in one of hagrid's more successful
lessons i might add he taught the
students about nifflers by hiding
leprechaun gold in the earth
each student was given a niffler and the
one who found the most gold would win
it was actually ron weasley's niffler
who ended up finding the most gold
of course nifflers have also been
featured even more in the fantastic
beasts movies
they're known for their gentle
disposition but their attraction to
anything shiny can make them rather
difficult to keep around
that being said they've proven to be
helpful creatures on more than one
occasion and could certainly have a role
in hogwarts legacy
number three the unicorn despite being
one of i would say
the most familiar and well-known
mythical beasts in our culture today
unicorns were featured surprisingly
little in the harry potter series
unfortunately the only time we actually
see a unicorn in the series is in book
one after voldemort has
killed i think actually two in the
forbidden forest the blood of the
unicorn was said to have such
powerful magical properties that it
would keep someone alive
even if they were an inch from death of
course it was said to come at a terrible
price which would curse the drinker from
the
moment the blood touched their lips
unicorns would pop
up occasionally throughout the rest of
the series in students lessons and exams
but they were never really featured as
prominently again as they were in book
one like
phoenix as though unicorns have such
potent magical capabilities that their
hairs are used in wands
garrick ollivander actually considered
them to be a supreme one core along with
phoenix feathers and
dragon heartstring number four
bowtruckles another
creature that has been featured
prominently in the fantastic beasts
movies but was first introduced to harry
potter fans via hagrid
is the bowtruckle these tree dwelling
creatures are only around 8 inches tall
they have long sharp fingers and their
stick-like figure makes them difficult
to spot among trees
now i personally think bowtruckles are
highly likely to be in hogwarts legacy
and here's why
there was actually a little island in
the black lake known as bowtruckle
island
this is of course where newt spent a lot
of time during his years at hogwarts he
would go to the island and learn about
the boat truckles in their native
habitat
newt being nude he was able to befriend
them in rather short order
he also took his friend leta lestrange
to the island in an attempt to cheer her
up when he found her by the lake
crying one day so with this being an
open world game where so much is set to
take place at hogwarts i'd actually be
pretty surprised if bow trickles don't
end up in the final game
number five speaking of other creatures
in
and around hogwarts what about the giant
squid
perhaps i should say a giant squid as
any squids we meet in hogwarts legacy
certainly wouldn't be the same squid
students talk of in harry's day
now here's an interesting tidbit on the
giant squid that comes to us courtesy of
the harry potter wiki
of course giant squids actually exist in
our own world but what we know about
them doesn't quite match up with the
giant squid we read about in harry
potter inhabiting the black lake
so i think this probably means this
giant squid is maybe a subspecies with
certain magical properties
in the harry potter series we know
students love to joke about the giant
squid and sometimes even seem to fear it
a little bit but everything we
know suggests that the giant squid at
least in the harry potter series is
harmless it didn't attack crumb in book
4 when he swam in the lake students were
able to feed it bread on occasion and it
actually even rescued dennis crevey when
he fell into the lake again
in book 4. all right for number six
let's stick with another aquatic
creature here and talk about the kelpie
unlike the giant squid these things are
incredibly
dangerous to humans kelpies are
shape-shifting water demons that are
said to
lurk in rivers and streams they usually
take on the appearance of a horse and
invite humans to
ride across if humans take the kelpie up
on the offer the beast will drag
the writer under and attempt to eat them
yes you heard me right
eat them newt actually managed to tame a
kelpie using a bridle
note to self though should you see a
horse in a river in hogwarts legacy do
not
attempt to ride it at number seven and
rounding out the water creatures for the
list we have the siren
sirens are actually the earliest
recorded race of mer people
in the wizarding world they were
exceptionally beautiful and it's
believed they used their singing voices
to
lure sailors into the water a siren is
depicted on the portrait from the
prefect's bathroom on the fifth
floor of hogwarts this portrait helped
the triwizard champions again book four
specifically cedric diggory in figuring
out the mystery of the golden egg
so even if we don't see an actual siren
in hogwarts legacy i'm definitely
interested to see if the one pictured in
the prefix bathroom makes an appearance
as we're exploring the castle
and at number eight we have the demi
guys a peaceful herbivore with two
insane magical abilities one the power
to become
invisible and two the power to see the
future
because of their pre-cognitive sight
they're insanely hard to catch
their pelts make them highly sought
after though as they're used in making
invisibility cloaks it's said that
cloaks made in this way eventually lose
their effect because the hairs turn
opaque over time you may remember again
newt scamander had a demiguise which
escaped in the middle of new york city
during his trip there in 1926.
at number nine let's talk werewolves of
all the beasts featured on this list i
would say the werewolf is one of the
most well-known throughout
all of harry potter lore thanks in large
part to remus lupin
unlike any other beast on this list
werewolves are of course
partly human there are numerous
variations of the werewolf throughout
popular culture and in the wizarding
world of harry potter they work
mostly in ways that we're familiar with
with the rising of the full moon the
humans suffering from lycanthropy is
transformed into an
uncontrollable wolf with no recollection
of their true identity
it's said a werewolf would even murder
their best friend if given the chance
now they have no control over the
transformation but perhaps most
frighteningly the memories of what they
do in werewolf form will actually remain
with them
when they return to human form should we
see any werewolves in hogwarts legacy
it's safe to say they will be thoroughly
shunned and mistreated by the majority
of the wizarding world
even lupin much later in the timeline
than what hogwarts legacy is said to
take place in
faced prejudice and discrimination in
what we read
we started the list with an incredibly
powerful bird in the phoenix and now
we have another immensely powerful bird
in the thunderbird
these golden and white birds are close
relatives of the phoenix and native to
north america
thunderbirds can actually create storms
around them and they're said to be
highly sensitive to danger
last but not least thunderbirds are also
one of the four house mascots at
ilvermorny school of witchcraft and
wizardry which is of course located in
north america
so unless we're heading to america at
some point in hogwarts legacy i have to
say i think the thunderbird is unlikely
as much as i would love to see one of
these things in a video game
the demiguise is found in the far east
so unfortunately i would say chances on
that one are low as well
both truckers have a high chance of
being in mainly because of the
aforementioned bowtruckle island located
on the black lake
i also feel pretty good about at least
seeing the tentacles of the giant squid
not really sure if we'll be able to
explore underwater or not
if we do get that underwater exploration
then it will almost certainly feature
mer people there and maybe kelpies as
well
now nifflers have appeared in both
fantastic beasts and the harry potter
series so i do expect we'll see nifflers
in the game there's a lot
avalanche could do in terms of gameplay
that take advantage of their magical
abilities to find
shiny objects as for unicorns and
werewolves i just
i can't get a really good feel on either
of these the game is hopefully going to
be a massive game with multiple quest
lines and a werewolf storyline
somewhere along the way would absolutely
serve that purpose well
that being said werewolves and unicorns
they've been done so many times so i
could see avalanche just electing to
stay away from them for the game
again though as we already pointed out
unicorns were actually featured
surprisingly
little in harry potter so maybe they
take the opportunity to do a little bit
more with the unicorn here
and then we have the phoenix this one is
so immensely popular
in the wizarding world and among fans
that i wouldn't be at all surprised to
see it however it's important to
remember it is a very
rare creature so i'd have to say this
one is a bit of a toss-up for me now if
you've missed any of our other videos on
the confirmed magical creatures or my
theory on how they'll play a huge role
in the game story you can check out
these two videos on the right side of
your screen now
as always thank you all so much for
watching keep each other safe
keep faith and i'll talk to you again
soon